Bob Lee the former ESPN outside the line
so Sports Center host and 11 times
sports Emmy winner announced his
retirement after 40 years of employment
there at ESPN how surprising was it the
reaction when you announced your
retirement stunning overwhelming the
most emotional professional experience
I've ever had my family's ever had it's
just it's incredible and it's gonna take
me weeks to properly try and circle back
to the people who have reached out and
and most people I'll never meet and you
know and if it's it was on Twitter it's
tough to get your arms around that but
they had Twitter and DMS and Facebook
and Facebook messages and handwritten
notes the lost I just it has been it's
been insanely gratifying and it at the
same time it kind of ratify right
decision right time right reasons mostly
personal and time to go and but it's
been insane it's been wild but you're
going to sabbatical yeah and what did
you find on that sabbatical were you
testing retirement kinda little test
drive company was great I can't say
enough of how patient they were how
understanding they were and when I left
it was prod needles probably in the
middle and some days a needle would move
one way and some days the needle would
move the other way and you know and when
you're sitting in in South Florida and
it's you know minus 15 up here it's a
little easier yeah but didn't miss the
grind and the grind is one of the reason
you want to step back but you know as
you well know the toughest part of
making a decision about step back the
people I mean you spend more time with
these jamokes right then you do with
your family right a true it's true and
and they become close friends and the
same is true when you're putting the
daily show together from 7 a.m. to 3
p.m. every day and on email incessantly
and these people there and people you
know I just spent some time today with
Robin Roberts Charley Steiner and Chris
lip-lock you know Christmas yeah we had
brunch after Good Morning America and
you know so much is nonverbal you just
you experience that as a group and to
not have that available every day that
that's the difficult part but you know
what all my retired friends said you'll
wonder if you had time to work how you
had the time and I'm after three weeks
I'll tell you it's
it's true calendars full III squeeze gin
though how do you replace it though
trying to do stuff for other people to
keep busy with my alma mater Seton Hall
Charlie and I were trading dueling
concert stories he thought that Ringo
with McCartney was gonna Trump
Springsteen coming out with Southside
Johnny and then I just seen little
Steven the other night so but this shows
reading books sleeping taking better
care of yourself
you'd be surprised I mean you know it's
like business well I tell the story to
these guys I would drink for 20 ounce
bottles of coke every night you and
Boomer together kept in business
yes but I I wanted to be energetic at
the end of not many jobs you have to be
your best at the end of a day and it
would be a 11 o'clock and I'd be wired
because I wanted to be energetic asleep
when you go and then I'd go home and I'd
drink three or four beers to go to bed
and then repeat not a good cycle no it
wasn't and we had no cafeteria there for
how many years it opened on the 25th
anniversary in 19 or 20 the 99 and you
know million the machines and you know
they sanded the sandwich lady but now
now it says you've been on outstanding
but and and I worked the other end of
the day but like breakfast was in eating
a bagel and trying to drink your tea
with one arm in your hand that you're
you know listening to the radio coming
in or on the phone and it's quarter to
6:00 in the morning when you you know
when you hit the road and it it's a lot
but look we got the best jobs in the
world or you have one and I had one of
them they are the best jobs in the world
we don't have problems I mean the guys
are working outside in this rain they
got issues think that's tough but if you
were just starting would ESPN be the
place you would want to be would they
hire me
probably not I was 24 with that it you
didn't have much experience I had three
years in local cable I could relocate
quickly I made them wait 18 hours for a
decision I had two job offers on
consecutive days Scottie's Walken Scotty
Connell walking me to the office two
weeks to the day before sound late
August 79 essentially offering me the
job and I he kind of bring him up short
I said mr. Connell I'm gonna have to get
back to you I've another job interview
tomorrow and I did in Newark with New
Jersey public television they offered me
the number two sports job
so I had at 18 hours make up my mind now
it's 79 ESPN's not on the air
this other job would put me on the air
weekends as a sports anchor at 24 years
of age in New York and Philly and then
reporting three days a week that's a
tough call in 1979 and the money was
identical and you know and one thing you
learn eventually is it you don't do
things for money in life it's tough to
say that all the time and so I made them
wait but I had just come out of a
situation where we had built this local
cable operation from nothing literally
the blueprints and you could design your
job and here's another chance to do it
but at what point did you go or did you
go I made a mistake I go into u.s. p.m.
no I don't think I ever would be those
days my first day I walked in at 10:00
a.m. and I walked out at 2:00 a.m. true
story
absolutely true story and I get back to
the Holiday Inn a new brand and I say
yeah and I say to myself gee I wonder if
I get my old job back the next morning
when I pull my head off the pillow but
no look so it wasn't like playing for
the New York Titans the checks always
cleared you didn't have to run to the
bank there was a period in the early 80s
when the rumors you know Ted Turner was
circling and we were not profitable for
a number of years and until ABC came and
I remember the seismic jolt of energy
that went through the company I think it
was 84 when ABC I exercise their option
and assume authority control which meant
we had stable ownership that believed in
the place and when I got there so I got
there in 1989 and this was the famous
Charlotte Observer line from Chris
Berman because I was there to observe so
our boss John Walsh said you know I want
you to observe for three months and I
just read months I gives you a blue
helmet just the Golan Heights right I
went too tight you know I came from CNN
that had the same format as SportsCenter
and so Chris Berman every time he'd see
me to go the Charlotte Observer I got to
the point where I said just put me on
the air just let me go yeah and Berman
just got through with the 11 o'clock and
I was gonna do I believe it the one
o'clock at the time and he said I'm
gonna stay and do your first show with
you they boot somebody off the show
yeah big-footed floated and he said I'm
gonna do it good and so there were two
moments that one with with Chris and
when I sent you a letter when I was in
Dayton Ohio and you had no idea who I
was and I sent a letter to you and Greg
Gumbel and I just said look look at this
tape and tell me if you see anything cuz
I I just lost the weekend job at channel
2 I didn't get the job I'd lost it and I
thought you know what I I can work at
SportsCenter I like that's the place I
want to be and I go I'm gonna send you a
letter and I sent this letter and all of
a sudden I get a letter back I tried to
find it yeah I would love to see it I
have a vague recollection wrote a full
letter to me I had matters in those you
had a type on a typewriter you had a
full letter to me saying you're not
ready now but ba ba ba ba ba and let you
know stay in touch kind of thing yeah
and I was walking on the moon for it it
really helped me stay in in the business
or at least you know an idea of wanting
to continue do because I was gonna get I
gave up hope and I was just gonna go you
know what let me see if somebody sees
something in me because I couldn't get a
job in local sports so of course in my
mind I can get a job at ESPN I can't
work at channel 2 in Dayton Ohio I mean
that again they hired me twenty four
three years of experience in local cable
doubled my salary to the princely sum of
$25,000 a year I was walking on air rich
yeah but and and do whatever you want to
do I mean I remember sitting across the
desk from Chet Simmons who was the
president he was the first president
Scotty Connell was the first executive
vice president and Chet gave you know he
was the guy who was the president of NBC
Sports gave that up to come aboard here
with Getti as the owner at ESPN and said
you know talk to sports fans the way
they want to be talked to we hired you
for your opinions I here's a Titan in
the industry me who I think that visit I
had to borrow my then girlfriend's
maverick with a stick shift and get up
there is my ship my car is in the shop I
can you know you have to bail it out to
move they had they hired me for what you
think and but they turned this loose and
I don't say left is a lie they left us
alone but they trusted us and they
trusted a lot of young people in the
beginning
if they hadn't done that I don't know
that you know the looking back at the
fiscal issues in the early 81-82
we might not have made it out of the
woods but we did and the other thing was
you know I Here I am
I send you a letter and then I don't
know how many years later it was but I'm
sitting next to you anchoring the 11
o'clock sports Internet and when I get
there
we're we're knee deep and petros
investigation and I had a local source
who was a bookie who was taking the off
bets from Pete's regular bookie so we
attack that as well as anybody I think
in the business covering that and I was
extremely proud of that but I was trying
to keep up with you and it made me a
better journalist because I was trying I
knew who you were and what you did and
how you did it I was just I didn't want
to be a high light guy I wanted to be a
guy who could do highlights but also
could do investigative reporting Lee and
I remember when we attacked it I was
proud that's probably the proudest thing
that I've ever been involved with at
ESPN was the way we we have approached
the Pete Rose situation you had your
sources I remember talking to a guy who
had been in a car overhearing Pete
making the bets and we got him on camera
there was no objective doubt we all knew
well before Bart Giamatti brought the
hammer down that that Pete had lied but
yeah that was that was insane what was
your best day at ESPN best show best
show most meaningful I don't know every
year I want to say this respectfully
every year Trey Wingo and I trade notes
on September 11th I mean here we are how
far are we from no not very very far
right blocks and were you in the office
that day I went home and got my kids out
us yeah I don't blame you and Barb did
the same with our girls and the debate
in the new I was on the phone with norbi
Williamson who's you know a major
executive still there at the time the
second tower fell I was scheduled to be
off you watching this I just said I'll
the question I was need me in there that
the image answered the question I'll be
an hour later I'm in there
the raging debate that day was what do
we do do we do anything and at the time
we were simulcasting ABC News you're in
shock the loss we didn't know anything
and eventually this very educated but
emotional debate yielded we're gonna do
an hour show that night and Trey and I
fell to us to write it and actually if
you go down to the 911 music and this
special exhibit it's still playing you
walk in there you see yourself it's
tough it's a mind you know and we try to
keep proper perspective the proper
relevance and and respect for that but
that day and that week we tried to each
day we went on with hours and hours of
coverage how sports was reacting to
something that we had never seen before
yeah and so your best not a most
meaningful can also be your worst day
too because of the gravity of what you
having yeah I mean I I look back when
when Tom Me's died and I'm ever going to
work and when Jim Valvano passed away
and I just I I did Jim Valvano man
because my dad died of cancer and I told
him the last day he was there before he
was done with the basketball season I
said Jim I want to apologize and I said
I purposely stayed away from you and you
know how gregarious center he's like why
do you know what's wrong I said because
I I didn't I didn't want to get to know
you more than you're not here anymore
and then I told him about my dad and the
first thing he said is how long was he
told he had to live and I said six
months he goes how long did he live and
I said six months and he was crestfallen
and he said will you do me a favor when
I die
put a great picture over your shoulder
he goes you know how you always have was
that picture over his shoulder when
you're doing a story on somebody he said
make sure it's a great picture of me and
it stayed with me so in the moment
you're trying not to cry yeah but it was
one of them I'm glad we did it the right
way and when the Indians relievers the
pitchers died in spring training and we
had to go through the land right now and
we had to go on that and I have like
those are the moments that stand out
because you're not known for
those things you're known for doing
highlights and that's where you want to
go you know what I want to be a
profession the greatest communal moment
working at ESPN would have been the year
you joined us October 17 1989 the World
Series earthquake yeah I was five rows
from the top of Candlestick Park and and
people ask me how long did it last and
the answer is long enough to start a
Hail Mary not long enough to finish it
because you were you were standing on
concrete and it was like standing on a
waterbed
and so but it stopped and Joe Torre is
sitting next to me he was doing analysis
and it within within less than 20
minutes our crew had us on the air we
had to get out around the stadium at the
center's field and that nobody could
communicate nobody had personal cell
phones back in those days was 1989 and
so everybody just instinctively knew
with their work ethic and their
commitment to a common mission what we
had to do and it can't turned on a dime
Joe said give me a cruel go ahead and
get some sound for you everybody just
pitched in and for two hours we were the
only live television out of a national
catastrophe I thought it was as good at
work as you've ever done and Al Michaels
you know he knew exactly what was
happening he you know you see the bridge
like he was telling you landmarks and
what's going on in the moment so you had
his expertise in a bird's-eye view and
then you and Joe Torre out in
centerfield reacting to this with the
players they were on the field there
hugging their wives they weren't sure
exactly what was happening was there
going to be a game I mean we were on the
air during an aftershock and we still a
camera on top of the San Francisco 49ers
scouting booth so you know anything
about optics you've got a zoom lens and
it magnifies the footage and they're
picking the bases up at that moment as
an aftershock hits so if there's any
question if we're going to play baseball
those images again answered the story we
have a presentation for you Josh spent a
little bit of time on I know you're on
Good Morning America with Robin Roberts
and she surprised you with Charley
Steiner and Charlie's a walking surprise
yeah Pauly would you bring over the big
surprise the presentation to Bob Lee we
just figure you have tons of Emmys you
may have a little room left on the
mantel in the office so
put this together okay good there we go
spend a lot of time on this and I hope
that you take this with the appreciation
that if you'd like to read it BOM Dan
Patrick show certificate of appreciation
almost spelled correctly yeah it got
close Bob I'm not gonna mention where
you teach I'll do that school the favor
and you the favor even though one of
your former students was speaking so
highly of you about two hours ago to me
award it to Rob Lee yeah thanks for a
whole lot of really really great work
yet hosting sports here in OTL and thank
you almost cherish this yeah no we
weren't sure how many Paulie said I
don't know thank you I just said put a
lot of years or really really long time
or something you know got most of the
name right six letters you got five of
them right it's close I mean what else
can you ask for can we get the newsroom
named after Tommy's can we get can we
get am I asking too much here Bob I know
that you know I've said why not build
you know you and Chris and Tom and you
want to name buildings there put a
statue of you three or whatever a
walkway but I just don't want Sports
Center to forget about those who came
before everybody before it wasn't cool
to work at sports day yeah that's all
that would be nice I mean we're coming
up on the 40th is gonna be some
celebration I don't know what they've
got up there up there asleep but that
you know Tom I got 22 years yeah
his daughter just got married about
three four weeks ago but yeah that would
be that would be the appropriate thing
there's a night you know they've
recognized some individuals in the
technical area I mean I said they did it
in the in the editorial and Tom would be
first on the list yes absolutely I think
it'd be great but even if you know they
do a statue like I don't want a statue
well there are pigeons in the world yeah
I don't I work with pigeons they do that
they do that to me every normally every
day yes would you have a beard or no
beard on your stage probably no beard
beards a an affectation of recent years
okay but you're not gonna go David
Letterman on oh hell no no no no this
gets trimmed about every five okay and
I'm not going the full monty okay
No thank you thank you thank you for
everything
a man it was it was fun it always was
fun you made it fun and if you ever get
bored I mean really really really bored
that would be like really really the
same number of regions here same idea
but like a World Cup and I provide the
wine
see now now you're getting another way
you pick the wine if you saw the the
farewell show they poured some salt I
sleep all that shap grabs it like he's
an Oliver Twist
you pick it up Jeremy by the gosh-darn
stem so you don't you know warm the wine
the wine you might have me in the boat
thank you thank you sir Bob Lee
everybody thanks guys for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]